[Music]
it was an
image that defined an era of space
exploration
in 1969 an estimated 600 million people
watched from their living rooms as
apollo 11's
eagle lander touched down on the moon
with one small step the united states
crossed
the finish line of the space race but
what if this event never happened
what if we never landed on the moon
could the cold war have ended sooner
would climate change be worse
and would you be lost all the time
this is what if and here's what might
have happened
if we had never landed on the moon
in 1957 the soviet union successfully
launched
sputnik the world's first artificial
satellite
into orbit by creating rocket technology
that defied the world's expectations
this launch was the opening shot that
started the race
to be first on the moon and the united
states
began in last place
as a response to the soviet union's
triumph
the united states created its space
agency
known as nasa dedicated to space
flight and scientific advancement this
agency
employed hundreds of thousands of the
most intelligent people on earth
to fulfill the goal of landing two u.s
astronauts on the moon and getting there
before the soviets
but if these missions never happened
would nasa exist today
a byproduct of the cold war the space
race
wasn't just about bragging rights
whoever got to the moon
first might control the earth later
but if the space race never kicked into
high gear
maybe the cold war could have ended
sooner a battle between
capitalism and communism that raged for
decades
the cold war was fought by proxy wars
and espionage
lasting from the end of world war ii to
the collapse of the soviet union this
conflict
affected every aspect of relations
between these powerful nations
from foreign policy to movie sequels
and if these two nations weren't
competing for scientific and
military supremacy via the space race
maybe some of those proxy wars would
never have been fought
during the height of the cold war in
1986 the stockpiles
contained almost 70 000 nuclear weapons
but if the focus had not been on rocket
technology
maybe the nuclear arms race would have
come to a standstill
of course if that had happened some of
the technology we used today
may never have been invented after a
tragic fire
killed the entire crew of apollo 1
nasa began developing highly resistant
clothing that could withstand
everything from liquid hydrogen to
melted gold
and by collaborating with firefighters
nasa helped
design breathing masks that had a wider
view
and were easier to wear without these
innovations
firefighters and emergency response
teams face
greater risks and they might be less
likely
to save your life okay
maybe that example is too extreme but if
you want to know how
technology has advanced our shared
culture
imagine life without your phone
today the microchip is the modern marvel
that
allows us to hold computers in our hands
instead of them being the size of
basketball courts
but before the microchip we had the
integrated circuit
developed to streamline more electronic
components
into one chip created for the apollo
missions to the moon
integrated circuits made technology more
available to the public
by shrinking the amount of space it
needed without the integrated circuit
the technology we carry in our pockets
might still be hanging on the walls
but what does that mean for the internet
well if there had been no trips to the
moon
it might have meant fewer trips to space
if those early test rockets had never
launched
the satellite networks we have now which
are put into place by rockets
may not exist nasa developed vehicles
powerful enough to carry objects over 36
000 kilometers above earth and put them
into geosynchronous orbits
that means the satellites orbit earth at
the same speed
as the earth is rotating without these
satellites orbiting over fixed points
the communications network that exists
today would
only be a fantasy that means no cat
videos
baking fails or what ifs
and forget about gps the global
positioning system
links into an interconnected network of
satellites to give
accurate locations anywhere on earth
with fewer satellites in orbit this
service
may not exist for civilians although
the military would still need precision
targeting
this military need may still have led us
to create
gps technology although it might have
taken longer to achieve it
that might not be true for the creation
of nasa though
after all the agency didn't exist until
after the soviet union launched its
sputnik but if nasa didn't have the moon
landing
as a goal its entire existence may have
been in question
if we're not trying to reach the moon
why would we need this
expensive space agency and the
technology invented to make space flight
cheaper and more practical might all be
theory instead of
reality reusable spacecraft like the
shuttles
would be as real as the starship
enterprise
we wouldn't see the images of our
universe captured by the hubble
telescope
it wouldn't exist and without satellites
monitoring weather conditions and
showing us the real-time effects we
might not
know the actual effects caused by
climate change
even advancements in health care might
have been delayed
to deal with the extreme temperatures of
space nasa developed
liquid cooling and ventilation garments
in 1966
this high-tech garment designed to
control your core temperature
is now being used by people with
multiple sclerosis
[Music]
while this aspect of the cold war began
with the fear of a nuclear showdown
these two superpowers
challenged each other in ingenuity and
curiosity
without this drive to explore beyond our
world
we wouldn't be talking about settling
mars now
nasa even has plans to land humans on an
asteroid but if we didn't have the
skills and
technology that allowed us to get to the
moon
we might not have tried something so
complicated
instead we might try something less
subtle
like what if we nuked an asteroid
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you